The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: So I'm
Arvind and this is Micah.
And we worked together on a
framework for flexible stream
processing on the cell.
So we were also oriented
towards an application which is,
in this case, a software radio.
And we used this
application as a case study.
Where is the mic?
I'll try and speak
as loud as I can.
So our project was about
flexible stream processing
framework for the cell.
And we used the software
radios as a case study,
essentially, of an
application you could
build using this framework.
The motivation for our
project is essentially
what we've been
discussing in class.
It's been reiterated.
The cell isn't easy to program.
There's no shared memory.
There's just message passing,
which is quite messy.
You have to explicitly
parallelize your programs
if you want to write them
as, say, custom C programs.
Some of the groups have
describe the challenges
they faced when doing that.
Extracting parallelism
can be tricky.
For example, if you want to
do pipelining, then on DSPs
you have to predict
what addresses
you're going to
require, and set up
a DMA so that those addresses
are fetched in advance.
And as Bill mentioned
in his talk in class,
stream programming can help
alleviate some of these issues
for some applications,
like software radio
where the applications
fit naturally
into the streaming model.
So what we tried to
do for our project
was build a light
weight-- as light weight
as possible because the
code has to fit on DSPs,
but as expressive as possible,
as well, so as to simplify life
for developers.
The streaming framework which is
targeted specifically at signal
processing applications.
The data model, at least, is
based on a research project
that I have worked
on in the past, which
is a WaveScope streaming
database management system.
It is is a research project
with the database group.
The data model is essentially
an extension of the streaming
model to handle
larger blocks of data
so as to process them better.
For example, several signal
processing operators,
like the fast Fourier
transform, need
to do multiple
passes over the data
and, therefore, trying to
treat streams on a sample
by sample basis
leads to high cost,
scheduling overhead, as
well as inefficiency.
So that's what the
data model does.
And we tried to port
this data model over
to the cell processor
and see how well we
could exploit the features
of the cell processor.
In particular, the high on-chip
bandwidth between the SPEs
to do with streaming.
So our case study was, as we
mentioned, a simple software
radio application.
It's really simple.
It uses incoherent demodulation,
as well as just simple
amplitude-shift key modulation.
As I said, the main
goals of our framework
were to simplify
life and modeling
as much parallelism
as possible-- try
and extract pipeline
parallelism, data parallelism.
Some of the kinds of
parallelism, We'll mention.
The kind of parallelism we were
able to finally implement--
so far, it's only
pipeline parallelism,
but as future work, we'd be
interested in the other kinds
of parallelism as well.
More about it as I go on.
So in the framework we
at least implemented,
the programming model
is quite simple.
The basic execution unit is
what we call an operator.
It's analogous to what in
StreamIt would be called a work
function, or what
in GNURadio, which
is a framework for
building soft radios,
would be called a block.
So these operators can be any
arbitrary C++ classes with
state, and they implement
an iterate method which
the developer has to overload
in order to process a block
of data.
The WaveScope data model
also provides a library
for managing memory and
passing blocks of signal
data between these operators.
Applications in
this model are built
by chaining operators together.
So this is a snippet
of some of the code
we wrote for the
software radio, roughly.
So you create a box,
let's say a FIRFilter,
which processes
elements of type float.
And then, it takes in
some arguments, initialize
the filters,
parameters, and so on.
You want to create a
white noise generator
and hook up the filter to
the white noise generator.
We use this to simulate a simple
channel, [INAUDIBLE] channel.
So I'll just describe the
components of our framework.
We have a lightweight scheduler
on both the PPE, as well as
the SPEs.
Right now, it uses a static
operator mapping in the sense
that you have to specify a
static configuration file,
where you say this operator
name will run on this [? SPU ?]
number.
But we've not completely
implemented dynamically
reconfiguring at runtime.
And we haven't yet seen
the need for doing that.
So it wouldn't be too
hard to add if needed.
But right now, you can
easily shuffle around
the operator mapping by
tweaking the configuration file.
Signal blocks, as I said,
were adapted from WaveScope.
They use reference counting
and avoid in-memory copies,
which can be quite expensive,
especially on the cell.
They also provide a convenient
API to manipulate signals.
So you don't have to do much
of the memory management
yourself or debug any
of the hard problems
to do with memory management.
We also ported this
library to ensure
that data is aligned for you
automatically and transported
via queues.
So one of the major
things we had to implement
was a queuing library and
remote heap management--
what amounted essentially to a
remote heap management library.
So in some sense, we
faced a choice here.
We could either
have the PPE control
and allocate memory statically
and make all the decisions
about what memory
is allocated where.
Or, we could have the
SPEs manage it themselves.
We decided to go for the
latter, partly because it
was more dynamic and, also,
because we weren't sure
what the implications of
all the control flow passing
through the PPE were for this.
So we chose the second approach,
which is autonomous memory
management.
So when an SPE sends a streaming
data element to another SPE,
it doesn't have to
actually explicitly request
the other SPE for
allocating memory.
It has a remote
heap interface so
that it can directly allocate
data and write to the SPE.
This is currently of
fixed size, but it
could be improved
by using this heap
to share a bunch of queues.
Right now, we have
one remote heap
for each queue between
operators on different SPEs.
So our system
automatically handles
pipelining streaming data from
SPE to SPE using the DMA API.
So Micah will takeover from here
and describe the software radio
implementation briefly.
MICAH BRODSKY: So our
software radio implementation
is relatively simple.
We weren't pushing
on that too hard,
especially because it took
the vast majority of our time
just to get the
framework to work.
Saving the programmer
trouble meant
that we inherited a lot
of trouble ourselves.
It breaks down to
about 25 boxes,
which we took in our
config file which
is manually mapped to the SPEs.
About 3,000 lines of code,
most of which is framework.
So I guess, if we were
more put-together,
we'd have a nice
diagram to show you.
There's enough time.
I'll try to draw a quick
diagram on the chalkboard.
We're simulating both sender,
receiver and a channel.
So the computation in
question looks something
like you have a bitstream.
You need to take
these and convert them
into some-- can
you read anything?
So you take stream of bits in.
Take bits.
Basically, use a
lookup mechanism
to convert it to
an analog waveform,
and filter that to
produce something
that has a narrower spectrum.
Running out of space here.
Means that.
Multiply that
against a sine wave.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN:
That's for modulation
MICAH BRODSKY: And so
you get-- you've probably
seen pictures of this.
It's very much like AM
It's basically binary
AM. [INAUDIBLE].
It's one of the simplest
things you can do.
Then, this is to
simulate a channel, which
is a random FIR filter,
finite impulse response.
What that means,
it's basically taking
the copies of the input
at different time offsets
with random coefficients
and just summing them up.
It's a huge multiply
add computation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So this is 80 taps.
And add some Gaussian noise.
And then this, we take
over, and then try
to figure out what we put
in in the first place.
So a bunch of filtering.
Again, more finite impulse
response filtering.
There's a little
closed loop that
tries to estimate the signal
amplitude and correct for it.
That's called
automatic gain control
to sort of keep it constant.
And I'm probably getting these
things a little out of order.
This is the incoherent
demodulation part.
We square the signal to
get rid of the carrier.
Automatic gain control.
Filtering.
There's another loop.
This is called a
phase lock loop.
The idea is try to match a
sine wave to some input signal.
I don't know how to
explain it very well.
It's basically a locking
type of detector.
The idea is to lock into the
phase of some periodic thing.
This is for recovering
when do you sample.
Because you've got
this messy waveform,
you've got to know when to
look and, say, OK, is it high,
is it low to get a bit out.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: [INAUDIBLE].
MICAH BRODSKY: Yeah.
I think that gives the picture.
I'm probably boring everybody.
Here's a picture
generated from the system.
So the green line
is the data in.
Hi, low. [INAUDIBLE].
The red line is
the analog signal
out right before it's
supposed to decide
what the heck the input was.
This is after squaring,
and filtering,
and automatic gain
control, and all that.
The little blips are
actually because we
used a modulation called
alternate-mark-inversion.
It basically flips every one.
That's why it's blipping
instead of being constant,
which is to be [INAUDIBLE].
And then the little blue
daggers are the results
of the phase lock loop to try
and recover when to sample.
And they're kind of off,
but they're kind of right.
And so, if you take
the little blue blip,
if the red line is
above 0, it's a 1.
And if it's below 0, it's 0.
And that's how you
get your bits out.
This was hard to get right,
mostly because of the framework
issues.
Implementing distributed
objects on a system
without real shared
memory is hard
because you have to
serialize everything
into a stream of
bits and deserialize.
So it really makes pie out of
any existing object oriented
code.
We did quite a bit of work to
get decent lock-free almost
zero-copy.
Another day or so,
we probably would
have gotten zero-copy--
transfer-- streaming
of the data from place to place.
And we had to keep the
code footprint low.
C++ is bloated.
We don't have an
overlay system yet to--
if SPE is not running
a particular box,
it still has to have
the code for it.
So we don't have any
infrastructure for--
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN:
There's some macros
to get around that, right?
MICAH BRODSKY: Yeah.
It's pretty messy.
So all the code is
on all the SPEs.
So code bloat is
particularly a issue.
And XLC has this
particular penchant
for runtime type information
and exception handling.
Incredible amount of voodoo
is necessary to get them
and that 70 K of useless
bloat out of there.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: We
pretty much have the--
MICAH BRODSKY: It
works, but not always.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN:
We did manage
to get it running long enough
to get some measurements.
MICAH BRODSKY: Yeah, we did
get some decent data out.
Running on the PPE only, we
can about 170,000 samples
per second through.
And with the scheduling file,
that's kind of rule of thumb--
we just roughly said, OK,
that looks about this big.
We'll throw it on
this SPE, SPE, SPE.
We got roughly four times
that using five SPEs.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN:
The core foorprints
are really large, but--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICAH BRODSKY: We
really had to push down
things like our queue.
We just didn't
have enough memory.
It sucked.
We basically just
said that already.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: Some
performance bottlenecks, I
guess.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICAH BRODSKY: Interesting
performance behavior.
We found that the SPEs are
ridiculously underutilized.
Most of the algorithms are
quite a bit zippier on the SPEs.
And so, they may be running
about a third of the time,
and the rest of time
just waiting for input.
And then the PPE, which is
doing only a tiny amount
of the computation-- basically
just feeding it in and sucking
it out-- is spending
half of its time all busy
and, the other half of the time,
stuck in flow control waiting
for queue space, which is-- our
flow control algorithm sucks.
Better with time.
So it seems like you
should be able to do
quite a bit better than we
did with a bit more work.
We need to cut
down the footprint.
And once we have a little
bit of breathing room
and get rid of the nasty
race bugs and such,
we can finally investigate
what was our original, pie
in the sky goal of
automatically deciding
what goes where, taking
measurements of the performance
and then feeding that
back to producing a better
placement of operators,
and applying data
parallelism by
instantiating operators
on multiple different SPEs
and splitting the data stream.
And just doing more.
AUDIENCE: Since your PPE is
at 40% to 50% utilization,
did you put actual
work on there?
MICAH BRODSKY: We did
put some work on there.
Actually, we put work
on there because we
couldn't fit all the
boxes-- the code for all
the boxes under the SPEs.
So we started strategically
to put a few things
at the beginning
and a few things
at the end which
weren't supposed
to be very
computationally intensive,
and yet they managed to
take up half the CPU.
The issue with the
other half of the CPU
is that it's actually
inside an inner loop
deep recursive in blocking
because, basically,
our back pressure
isn't online yet.
So if it tries to emit
something to a queue,
and that queue is
full, it just stops.
And it really could be running
a whole bunch of other stuff,
but it's not smart
enough to do that ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICAH BRODSKY: Unlike
a model like StreamIt,
everything here is
asynchronous and code driven.
The SPUs they can decide on
the fly how much to emit.
The programmer doesn't
have to declare anything,
But it means everything's
asynchronous.
And so you basically
[? race the issues ?] galore.
AUDIENCE: But in this
a application, do you
find any dynamic rates?
MICAH BRODSKY: In this
application, there's not much.
It's a very simple application.
If we actually went
to packetization,
error correction,
compression, things like that,
we'd probably see
a lot more of that.
This is definitely
underutilized in
the asynchronous
capabilities of the system.
AUDIENCE: In the case
of radio, wouldn't it
be OK to draw [INAUDIBLE]
frame into audio data
just because you're spending
so much time waiting,
it'd be better just to
relieve pressure on the queues
by just dropping some
frames that are unnecessary.
MICAH BRODSKY: It might well be.
AUDIENCE: And
interpolating it in the end
to try to fix it
up a little bit.
MICAH BRODSKY: It might well be.
We decided not to
do that as a part
of the framework because
[INAUDIBLE] policy decision,
and we didn't want to make that
for all possible applications.
But if we figure out a
good way to dispose that,
that definitely
would be an option.
Just drop a few packets.
Drop a few samples.
AUDIENCE: So what
about buffer sizes?
Do you declare the
buffer size as well?
MICAH BRODSKY: Yeah.
The way we have it
now-- there's actually
just a #define in the code that
says all buffers are this size.
AUDIENCE: Do you need any
double buffering in there?
MICAH BRODSKY:
You don't need it.
Well, actually, the way
it works is that there's
this remote heap input queue.
And an upstream SPE just DMAs
things in as it feels like.
And then the
downstream SPE looks.
Is there something here?
Grab it, use it.
So it just works, however
much buffering there is.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: The ring
buffer and the [INAUDIBLE]
should get that
block [? free. ?]
MICAH BRODSKY: That's a benefit
of the asynchronous approach.
It just works, if you have
memory, which we don't.
Queues are tiny.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
is angrily telling me
that his connection dropped but
he's not picking up the phone.
Yeah, I could see it in there.
AUDIENCE: Any other
questions for them?
Did you want to do the demo?
MICAH BRODSKY: Nah.
SPEAKER ON PHONE: What did
you do to get race conditions?
MICAH BRODSKY: How
did we manage to get
ourselves race conditions?
Well, it's a mix of the
fact that all the SPUs
can essentially operate
as independent threads
and are sort of
asynchronously DMAing things
to each other and
somewhat poor--
legacy driven architectural
decisions on the way the PPU
code works.
Because we ported a lot of code
from the WaveScope platform.
[?
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: Which
wasn't very ?] well documented.
MICAH BRODSKY: And
that was intended
to be multithreaded
with Pthreads, which
in our original, naive before
we actually started the class
impression, we
thought we were just
going to port the whole
thing and use Pthreads
on the sub, which of
course is not possible.
So there were still some
threaded components in there.
And we introduced a lot of
bugs trying to port the thing.
See if i can--
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN: The
surprising thing was the fact
that we had to replace
array constructors in order
to eliminate [? RTTI. ?]
And it was just a big deal
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICAH BRODSKY: We had
to get rid of new,
we had to get rid of delete.
We had to get rid of
array constructors.
We had to get rid of--
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN:
Virtual destructors.
MICAH BRODSKY: --pure
virtual functions
and virtual destructors.
It was a mess.
I guess one more
pithy thing I could
say about race conditions
is it's incredible
how many subtle race
conditions and bugs we found in
the remote keeping
queueing library.
Because there's one-- it's a
lock free asynchronous data
structure.
There are two threads-- two
SPUs reading and writing from it
at the same time.
And there's all sorts
of little subtleties
where if you get it
a little bit wrong,
you end up with one of the
queue pointers overrunning
the other guy, and
you have basically
dangling pointers
and things like that.
At least three or four
times, we spent a few hours
until we discovered that was the
cause of mysterious behavior.
AUDIENCE: Anything else?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]